hi i'm christine goodwin on this episode
of the fox news rundown
senate democrats are moving forward with
president biden's 1.9 trillion dollar
coronavirus relief package
but they still face several hurdles
fellow democratic lawmakers say the plan
needs more safeguards to protect
out-of-work americans while republicans
oppose more stimulus spending
slamming the bill's price tag gop
senator john barrasso of wyoming
and democratic congresswoman alyssa
slotkin of michigan share their thoughts
on the package
and what they say the nation needs to
recover from the economic
crisis texas governor greg abbott
sparking a mix of reactions
announcing plans to end the statewide
mass mandate
and to allow businesses to return to 100
capacity
fox news sunday host chris wallace
weighs in on the lone star state rolling
back covet 19 restrictions
and the sexual harassment allegations
against new york governor andrew cuomo
plus commentary from brian kilmeade host
of the bryant killmead show
the fox news rundown is a daily news
podcast where we
take a deeper look at the stories
important to you you can subscribe
on your favorite podcast player by going
to foxnewspodcast.com
i'm jerry willis i'm steve ducey i'm
shannon breme and this
is the fox news rundown
friday march 5th 2021 i'm lisa brady
the centerpiece of the president's
pandemic response is nearing the finish
line
despite complaints about a partisan
process
after the elections you have a 50 50
senate
and you have a house with very narrow
margins you know that should be a
mandate to move to the middle i'm chris
foster
senate republicans aren't making it easy
but democrats are on track to pass their
big commercial virus financial relief
and stimulus bill
if they don't pass this it seems to me
i mean i don't want to overstate but it
almost feels like the bible presidency
would be over and
and that that democrats uh control of
congress would be over
i i just don't know how you'd come back
from something like that we speak with
fox news sunday host chris wallace
and i'm brian kilmi i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
[Music]
covid relief hits the senate floor the
senate being equally divided
the vice president votes in the
affirmative and the motion to proceed
is agreed to vice president kamala
harris casting the tie-breaking vote to
begin debate
on the 1.9 trillion dollar package
president biden calls the american
rescue plan
though debate quickly hit a procedural
speed bump
title ix committee on finance subtitle a
crisis support for unemployed workers
clerks reading the 628-page bill on the
senate floor
after wisconsin republican ron johnson
objected to the routine request
to waive the reading democrats say
delays won't stop it from passing
senate majority leader chuck schumer the
time is now
to move forward with big bold
strong relief it is time to tell the
american people
that help is on the way but republicans
say it's more wish list
than rescue the bernie sanders wing of
the democrat party
is running the show up here on capitol
hill and this is the first step
senate minority whip john thune says
republicans were cut out of the process
on the second largest spending bill in
u.s history behind last year's cares act
the president did meet with some
republican lawmakers and is backing a
change that makes
fewer americans eligible for stimulus
checks based on income
but the white house insists the entire
package is needed
to help survive the pandemic and speed
recovery
republicans are united that there is
some assistance that's needed but not
what we're looking at here with this
democrat bloated bill which isn't really
about covet relief
wyoming republican senator john barrasso
it is a wish list
of uh liberal spending it is packed with
pork
it is so much unrelated to coronavirus
and the democrats seem to be rushing to
do this
because they realize that with almost
two million people being vaccinated
every day
and with enough people that have had the
disease itself having
now a future immunity likely that um
that they're running out of time to get
their hands in the federal till and add
to the debt
to such a tremendous amount of money now
i know that some things have been taken
out
the minimum wage increase because of the
parliamentarians ruling on that
also a transportation project in san
francisco another one in
uh northern new york that had been
criticized
um and there has been a change to lower
the
income caps at least a proposed change
to lower the income
caps on the stimulus checks does any of
that
make it better in your view the total
spending dollar figure is still much
much
too high i mean it's almost hard to
imagine how much 1.9 trillion dollars is
that's
similar to what we did with the cares
act of a full year ago
and the situation is so different in the
country now with many places
back open kids back in school is
certainly in wyoming
although nationally kids have fallen
behind because of the teachers unions
who continue to
boycott efforts to get so many more kids
back to school
one of the biggest measures dollar wise
is the payoff to the blue states
the money that goes to new york in
california in illinois
which so much is related to the fact
that they kept their economies locked
down the longest
they have a special formula in this bill
that penalizes states
that opened sooner got people back to
work got kids back to school
and this is basically a payoff of the
the states
that were supportive of president biden
he kind of winked at you with them and
said you get me elected
i'm going to make sure you get paid off
big time and that's what he's doing for
new york
california and illinois where would you
want to see
money going in this bill if you could
scratch it and you know start all over
again to me coronavirus relief is
getting people back to work getting kids
back to school
and getting the disease behind us so you
want to make sure we can get
everyone vaccinated who wants to be
vaccinated you want to make sure there's
testing that there's a good distribution
network you want to make sure that
schools are actually open
and if the school's not ready to open or
willing to open they shouldn't be
getting money
this bill has money for education in it
ninety five percent of that money
doesn't even start to get spent
until twenty twenty two well after we
have coronavirus
behind us so i don't think we need to do
any of that that is a payoff to the
teachers unions they sent joe biden
a ransom note and he was happy to pay it
he made all types of big-time promises
about getting kids
back to school he deserves an f grade on
that
because he's completely failed
to put kids first what about the fact
that democrats
are using a budget process
that doesn't require republican support
to pass it
how much could that maybe help
republicans in the twenty twenty two
midterms
you know this is a time when after the
elections
you have a fifty fifty senate and you
have a house with very narrow margins
you know that should be a mandate to
move to the middle and president biden
in his inaugural address
talked about unity his entire campaign
was about
compromise and bringing people together
and right after the inaugural
address he threw that unity message and
speech out the window
and and said nope we're going full far
to the left
uh he did meet with a number of
republican senators who brought
a package together of uh much a smaller
but still significant piece of
legislation that dealt with the kids
back to school
dealt with people back to work and dealt
with just the disease component of it
uh and he seemed ex receptive but his
staff
did not they set with their arms uh
folded and shaking their head no
and that's the position now that
president biden has taken my way or the
highway
in spite of the fact that the the voters
of america uh have in this election
senate 50 senate to washington another
question being raised is whether a bill
this size is still needed
now that millions of americans are being
vaccinated against covid
every day i think that you know part of
the the reason we're seeing that light
at the end of the tunnel is because
people are getting shots in arms
more and more of us are getting
vaccinated and
you know a big portion of this bill is
money towards
our vaccine infrastructure michigan
democratic congresswoman alyssa slotkin
i know that we are aiming to get to the
point where we can have these mass
vaccination sites you know 25 000 people
coming to a stadium over the course of a
day
um to get vaccinated once we get into
sort of you know younger ages
so we got to pay for that that's
certainly part of it
um but i also think there are some bills
that have
been pushed off and pushed off and
pushed off and
that this bill helps cover um most
importantly is money for state and
locals
right i don't think people appreciate
that we haven't seen the revenues for
some of our cities and some of our
counties that we would normally see that
we've seen them spend a ton of money to
try to make things kind of coveted
friendly
and it's frankly my mayor's and my
police chiefs and my fire chiefs who are
telling me
that we've got holes in our budgets and
if we don't have help there's going to
come a point where we have to start
doing layoffs and cutting
cutting city services so um you know
is there is the bill perfect no um
but do i think that it's an important uh
signal and shot in the arm
yes what do you say to people who still
aren't sure
exactly what's in it who maybe have
heard the republican complaints that
it's too much spending not directly
related to covid
like the arts or museum funding or
that money for states you know might be
considered a bailout or even a payout to
democratic states supportive of the
president
yeah well on the state and local money
i've heard that complaint but this is
why
we put extremely tight constraints on
how that money can be spent
because i don't believe in bailing out
states and cities
that had pre-existing debt uh
uninsolvent pensions
you know things that pre-existed before
covet this is for covet and if you can't
prove that it's directly connected to
your covid costs
um then you're not gonna be able to use
the money in the same way
so um i i feel like um that complaint of
it
a blue state bailout is it's a nice
slogan but i don't think it's accurate
are you concerned at all about the
process
that essentially going it alone passing
it without republican support
could backfire on democrats in the
midterms
um you know i didn't like the process
i'll be honest i had called
early on for us to negotiate this
coveted
package the same way we we did the
previous four which was
really hard fought um negotiation
between democrats republicans house and
senate and the white house
um and obviously you know the control of
the senate flipped in the meantime and
the control of the white house
but i still believed that that was the
best way to do covet relief
um you know you don't win every battle
when you're just one member of congress
but i i will say i still think if you
ask the average
person they are interested in some form
of additional covet assistance whether
it's for them or for small businesses
i'm not sure that two years from now
someone's going to be saying
well you shouldn't have passed a coveted
bill when you did
we got a lot of time between now and
then and
we have to deliver there is a proposal
to keep
some national guard troops in dc for
another two months and you put out a
statement
critical of that at least until there's
more information
about why correct why did you put that
statement out
well listen i mean i i have a a view of
this because the michigan national guard
is in charge right now of security
around the capitol we are are leading
um all of the national guard troops who
are here um
and they they flagged for me that you
know on march 12th their mandate ends
and
they hadn't heard what was going to
happen afterwards you know
i i will tell you i just no one likes
seeing
um sort of the fortress-like atmosphere
around the us capitol
no one likes seeing really tall fences
you know with razor wire on top and
uniforms
um protecting the capital it's a
symbolic place so we don't like that
um so i want to understand the threats
and then
you know that drove the decision to ask
for a 60-day extension
i i think we as members of congress who
work here we should uh have the right to
get a security briefing
but then also i want to know what the
plan is to off-ramp
the national guard and have it you know
have us go back to a place where the
capitol police are able to protect us
um and that off-ramp plan um
is something that i wouldn't expect to
see
before we move ahead on approving
another two months
what have you taken away from the
multiple hearings that have been held
now
on the january attack because there
certainly has been some
conflicting testimony about who knew how
much
ahead of time and then the response
during the riot
yeah i mean this is why i really believe
we need a truly bipartisan commission
to take a stand back look at this and
not
just do this through various hearings
and committee meetings because
what is clear to me is that the threat
was not taken seriously
i'm from michigan so we've been dealing
with these kinds of problems for over a
year
i knew there was going to be violence
that day i said i told my staff in
writing the day before
no one is to come into the office
because i knew there'd be violence i
just thought it would be outside on the
lawn
i didn't think they'd ever get in so
they clearly underestimated the threat
they clearly did not request enough
forces ahead of time from the national
guard
and clearly there was no quick reaction
force waiting nearby
which seems to me to be a pretty
egregious mistake
representative slotkin is also a former
defense department official and cia
analyst and her concern about capital
security issues and how they're being
handled
is something that crosses the political
aisle the security i believe right now
is uh excessive
around the capital we do have members of
the wyoming national guard who are here
i've met with them took them on a tour
of the rotunda in the capitol building
it's time for them to go home
it's time for the guard to go home it is
time to get our country
uh back to uh to where it was previously
that these
razor wires and fences uh and need to
come down
and uh we need to allow uh a better
interaction with government
and uh the people that we elect uh to
serve the folks of this country
wyoming senator john barrasso thank you
very much for your time sir we
appreciate it
thanks
this is brian kilmeade with your fox
news commentary
coming up a year ago there were no
coronavirus restrictions in the united
states but they were coming soon though
and now some governors have been saying
that with case numbers going down and
vaccination numbers going up
enough's enough some restrictions in
michigan are eased starting today
mass mandates and other restrictions
were lifted in mississippi wednesday
they're ending in texas
next wednesday president biden says
about easing up now with the vaccination
process speeding up
the last thing we need is neanderthal
thinking texas governor greg abbott
tells fox
where we are today is completely
different from where we were this time
last year when texans and americans
didn't know how to deal with this
for an entire year texans have learned
the best practice and that is to wear a
mask and we still
strongly recommend that people do wear a
mask the seven-day average of cases
hospitalizations and deaths are trending
down nationwide
we seem to be making progress there's no
question for making progress
from the height of the of the disease in
uh january having said that we still get
50 60 000 new cases a day
2 000 new deaths a day we speak with fox
news sunday host chris wallace
texas does not have a particularly
sterling record cases are up in texas
uh and they're 48th in in states in
vaccinations
so why is this a point you know
it's one thing if you're going to relax
a little bit but you're going to end the
mask mandate next week and you're going
to say everything every place can go
to a hundred percent capacity
restaurants stores
theaters gyms i don't not sure i
understand that
some individual businesses and business
chains are going to say nope you need a
mass to come in here but now you're
putting
you know retail workers and food service
workers in the position of being the
mass cop
yes that's exactly right in addition to
which i mean it's look it sends a
message
a lot of people don't follow this as
closely my guess is as you and i do
because they actually have real lives
and real jobs
and this is what we do for a living but
you know if there's a message the
governor thinks it's safe to go to 100
capacity in a restaurant some
restaurants are going to open 100
and some people are going to think it's
safe to go and just it clearly
sends a message and uh i you know it's
that it's okay
to let your foot off the brakes and you
know when you hear that and then you
hear
uh dr wolenski the head of the centers
for disease control
say uh this isn't the time to do it
we're not there yet uh i'm i'm just
concerned
that you know what what have we seen
over and over again in this thing we
opened
too quickly in april and may of last
year and then we had that huge spike
in july uh you know we opened again too
quickly towards the end
of 2020 and we had a huge spike in
january we're doing
so well right now the cases are coming
down we could do a lot better but where
cases are coming down
more and more people are being
vaccinated i you know i guess my feeling
is i would
prefer that we kept more boundaries on
a little while longer and maybe we can
really get the good situation
you know to that herd immunity that we
keep all hoping for
on the economic side it's looking like
this chronovirus financial relief
package is going to get passed by the
senate at some point with some tinkering
away from the house version now senate
minority leader mcconnell says it's too
late for a bill
this big to your point that we are
seeing of some light at the end of the
tunnel
vaccines here the economy is going to
come back on its own republicans say
it's a very very big bill but there are
still a lot of people in businesses who
are going to need help for a while
yeah i mean look you can argue the
merits of it and that's certainly a
legitimate thing to do
you can't argue the politics of it uh
joe biden and the democratic majority
have staked
their entire credibility on this bill
uh i cannot imagine that this bill
in some form of it maybe as you say it
gets tinkered now it's
it once you make more than 80 000 you
don't get any money strikes me as
perfectly reasonable a family making
160 000 you don't get any money
my guess is it could be even a little
lower than that but
uh you know they got to pass a bill if
they don't i i just think
you know if they can't do it on this on
an issue where they don't need 60 votes
because of budget reconciliation they
can pass it with 51.
if they don't pass this it seems to me
i mean i don't want to overstate but it
almost feels like the biden presidency
would be over
and and that that democrats uh
control of congress would be over i i
just don't know how you'd come back from
something like that
well after this does get passed
presumably we may see
a pretty harsh stall in legislation that
democrats want to get done this voting
rights bill and the police reform bill
that just passed they don't have
or they don't appear to have the 60
votes in the senate and even if
democratic leadership okay says enough
let's kill the filibuster they don't
have the votes to do that no i agree
uh you know i think they'll be able to
pass one more economic bill the big that
this is the rescue plan the coveted
relief plan
they're also talking about a recovery
plan the sort of build back better plan
which uh they can also pass under budget
reconciliation and my guess is they get
that through
but a lot of this legislation uh
i agree with you has no chance in the
senate because
they they can't pass the filibuster and
they can't kill the filibuster
the one area i don't know there's some
areas that i think they might be able to
i think the minimum wage
conceivably they could pass something it
wouldn't be 15
an hour it might be 10 or 11 an hour
you know i i have to say that that i you
know i was kind of shocked when i saw
that the
uh i didn't know the minimum wage is
seven dollars and 25 cents an hour
and it hasn't been increased since 2009.
seems to me there's something maybe it's
not 15
maybe it's 12 maybe it's 11 and maybe it
doesn't happen all at once and you phase
it in over three or four years
but it seems to me that there's should
be some bipartisan support
for something 725 that's 12 years old
feels
awfully you know out of date yeah and
i'm not an economist and i'm not a
mathematician and i'm not a labor expert
but i read something
basically saying look if you
extrapolated past minimum wages to boom
times and compared it to current gdp and
etcetera etcetera it really should be
more like 23 an hour
yeah uh again i you know i don't know
what the right number is
and and and again it may be less a
matter of the merits of it and more a
matter of the politics of it
but somewhere between 7.25 an hour and
15 dollars an hour i think there's
probably a sweet spot
that you could get 10 republicans to go
along with
50 democrats and and passable yeah
a lot of reporters chris did not like or
believe everything that donald trump
said but as we've talked about he was
quite accessible compared especially
uh to president biden now is this just
different styles of governing or would
you like to see the president take more
questions and be out there more other
than just making the plan statements
that he makes
is that a true question maybe everyone
said no i don't want to
well there were moments during the trump
presidency when i could have done with a
little less of them
but yeah absolutely he needs to be out
more he needs to do more interviews he
i don't think he's had a real formal
press conference yet and we're
uh you know more than a month into his
presidency
um you know there's been this
interesting thing that it seems like the
biden handlers
are a little bit afraid of him and a
little bit afraid of what he might do
um you know i i to a certain degree i
could see
him waiting until they get this uh
covered relief package passed they hope
to get it passed by
uh the 14th which i guess is a week from
sunday
and uh you know i think that shortly
thereafter you're going to see a speech
to a joint session of congress
and you know it seems to me that might
be an appropriate point to hold a news
conference and start
uh you know being more accessible to
more reporters having said that
i you know i learned something uh during
my years covering the reagan
administration
if you don't tell us how to cover our
stories we don't tell you how to cover
the government how to run your
government
uh last time i checked the the biden
white house was not asking either you
or me for advice on how they should
handle this communication strategy
well chris run another round of this
cancel culture debate it's maybe i don't
know if it's another round maybe just
never ends and mr and mrs potato head
we're in the news for a minute with
hasbro
dropping that branding and now it's dr
seuss do you find this stuff tiresome
or interesting to see how things change
and why they change
um i did yes is the answer i mean i i
find it tiresome in some cases
and and foolish i know i did mr potato
head really
um on the other hand there are times
when when and i
the out there is an outrage industry you
know there's an industry that that
that that makes money and certainly
makes waves
by creating outrages and um
and and controversies and forcing people
to go into their corners
uh i i i think it's
in some cases it's a case of people
being enlightened in other cases it
seems to me
it's a case of being taking political
correctness too far
uh and you know i don't know that i can
define the line but as potter stewart
said about
uh obscenity in the supreme court i
can't define it but i know it's when i
see it
all right let me get one more from you
i'm also getting a lot of coverage on
fox lately besides dr
seuss new york governor andrew cuomo
over the course of a year
has gone from getting raves for these
daily coronavirus updates to more people
remembering oh
oh yeah i forgot we actually don't like
andrew cuomo after all
yeah i mean talk about uh
the highs and the lows in the in in just
a year
um the problem he's got now is
i mean it's got a lot of problems first
of all there's a substantive problem of
what he did
in in ordering uh the nursing homes
except
people who had covered for an
understandable reason which was
the to overlook to relieve the overload
in
hospitals but you know it turned out to
be a disastrous policy then there's a
question of
did they come clean with the numbers
they clearly didn't that's now under
federal investigation
and now these allegations about about
the women
uh you know the problem is that
basically uh he's he's a fairly
unlikable guy
pretty unlikable guy and a bully and
people seem to have forgotten that
during
uh his his period when he was giving i
thought very effective
briefings and but now people are
remembering that
and you know he doesn't have a lot of
fans he's been a bully of reporters he's
been a bully
to his fellow democrats i mean you can
just see the delight
in mayor bill de blasio's eyes as he
takes the
the knife and sticks it in and twists it
a few times
uh almost every day on cuomo you know
you
you tick off that many people over that
many years and he's
into his third term as governor of of
new york
uh when you're on the when you're
when you hit the scheds and you start
heading down there aren't a lot of
safety nets out there for you
all right chris i feel like we've gotten
a lot done so i'll let you go fox news
sunday host
chris wallace on the fox news rundown
thanks chris
you bet thanks chris my pleasure
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand
fox news radio and the fox news app
download it today
rate and review the fox news rundown on
apple podcasts or wherever you listen
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
one new york city artist has been giving
survivors of covet 19 victims something
that the pandemic has taken away from so
many
a place to mourn their loss christina
libby started the floral heart
project and she creates beautiful
heart-shaped wreaths out of flowers
and then displays them in public places
she told the associated press that when
she began the project early in the
pandemic she was thinking of the people
who had to give their goodbyes to
friends and family members dying of
covet 19
through a phone or facetime not by their
bedside
she was saddened that they had no public
memorials so she decided to do something
about it
the floral memorials have become spaces
not just for those grieving a family
member's loss
but for those who want to have a moment
of silence in remembrance of others
or of their own losses she says she
wants the idea to grow
eventually having wreaths in all 50
states
libby's website has a sign up page for
those who would like to bring a floral
heart to their own city
to learn more about it and to see the
beautiful arrangements go to
floralheartproject.com
in new york city tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
try and kill me
what's on your mind i'm gonna talk about
what just happened last week at cpac
and with amongst republicans to let you
know what is next in 2024 should
donald trump getting some legal problems
and not be able to run or not be healthy
enough to run
here's what i can expect vice president
pence to put his hat in the ring senator
tim scott lookout
mike pompeo governor ron desantis
christy gnome nikki haley
marco rubio ted cruz josh hawley one
thing i will say that is a quality field
that the democrats cannot match because
it's almost certainly
joe biden will not have an opportunity
to run another four years i don't know
if he's going to get through another
four months
out of this entire class if i was to say
and bet on someone today
nobody would be ahead of governor ron
desantis
on pure performance alone with a rich
ivy league background with a military
experience with
a knowledge of washington only coming
from congress and now running one of the
most important states on the red side
and maybe in the country
fastest growing as well and most
respected florida
ron desantis has a leg up i'm perfectly
aware that it's
very short term i know that it all comes
down to him winning re-election as well
nikki haley i thought was a front-runner
until she took on
the former president a few weeks ago has
been able to speak to him since
but if i was to say a dark horse someone
coming up the side that should not be
discounted
it's scott's rick scott tim scott both
are extremely accomplished both
extremely dedicated both extremely smart
and experienced
it's got to be exciting and it's never
too early to speculate
on the horse race i'm brian kilmeade
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown stay up to date by subscribing
to this podcast at foxnewspodcasts.com
and for up to the minute news go to
foxnews.com
from the fox news podcasts network
subscribe and listen to the trey gowdy
podcast
former federal prosecutor and four-term
u.s congressman from south carolina
brings you a one-of-a-kind podcast
subscribe and listen now by going to
foxnewspodcast.com
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust
and click the fox news rundown playlist
for the latest episodes